hi i'm mark sorrells professor of plant
breeding genetics at cornell university
and i've been here since 1978 and
really have
enjoyed working here at cornell
my main responsibility here is to
develop new varieties of oatsweet and
barley for the northeastern u.s
focus of my research is on developing
new breeding methods
i'm going to start with a little bit of
information about our breeding program
here at cornell i have three technicians
david bencher is our research support
specialist
james tanaka is our lab technician and
josh connect is our field assistant
i also have a postdoc by the name of
lauren brazalski working on oat
metabolomics
i have several graduate students
dan sweeney just graduated and he's
currently breeding popcorn in in indiana
chitayama gursa just graduated and she's
now a durham wheat breeder in ethiopia
ellie toggin is from seattle
and she is currently on a six-month
internship with bayer crop science based
in st louis missouri
carl kunzi is from wyoming new york and
his uh project is to develop new
varieties of naked barley and winter
malting barley for the northeastern u.s
last and also travis rooney is from
college station texas
he's studying the impact of storage on
malting quality and seed dormancy in
pre-over sprouting resistant
spring malting barley
i have a new graduate student just just
joined us last week her name is kay
mcnary and she's from
missouri
she's currently working on the project
called value added grains for local and
regional food systems that i'll tell you
about more about in just a minute
[Applause]
cornell small grains project has a long
history
liberty high bailey established the
department of plant breeding in 1907
and
also
that same year dr h.j weber initiated
the small grains breeding project
dr harry hauser love came to the
department
as a graduate student in 1908
and in that following year he assumed
supervision of the small grains breeding
program
dr love expanded and continued to small
grains breeding at cornell university
until his retirement in 1949.
dr neil jensen came to cornell as a
graduate student in 1945
and he became the program leader in 1949
and myself i joined the project in 1978
and dr jensen retired in 1979.
since 1907 this breeding program has
released 34 winter wheat varieties
23 spring oat
seven winter
winter barley varieties
and four spring barley varieties
small grains are grown on more than
three hundred thousand acres in new york
and are valued at more than 1.5 million
dollars annually
our most recent variety releases are a
soft white winter wheat variety
that have very high levels of fusarium
headlight resistance a trait that's very
important for the northeast
we also released a spring malting barley
variety named excelsior gold
excelsior gold is the first spring
malting barley developed by cornell that
is well adapted to new york growing
conditions
we went from the first cross
in 2016
to certified seed production this year
this variety was developed in record
time
and is currently being grown for
certified seed production in this region
in the year 2012 new york state passed
the farm brewery law that gave tax and
marketing incentives
to breweries provided that they used at
least 60 percent of new york grown
ingredients in their in their brew
that stimulated the craft brewing
industry and today
new york state has the second most
breweries in the united states with more
than 440 licensed breweries
and they produce
more than a 1.2 million barrels of craft
beer annually
some of our currently funded projects
include
a project funded by the new world
foundation
on revitalizing grain production in the
hudson valley this is an important
project because it provides
organic vegetable growers in the hudson
valley
with options for rotating out of
vegetables into a high value food grain
new york state ag and markets supports
our research and extension for malting
barley production in this state
we also collaborate with jesse poland at
kansas state university on a usdaid
funded project
to develop high-yielding climate
resilient wheat varieties for south asia
using genomic selection
and then the brewers association is
funding a project titled impact of
storage on malting quality and seed
dormancy
in pre-over sprouting resistant spring
malting barley
we also have several usda funded
projects
including a project
funded by the
usda
wheat coordinated
agriculture project
that dr george debkowski at uc davis
leads
it's called validation and
characterization and deployment of qtl
for grain yield components in wheat we
also receive funding from the u.s
wheaton barley scab initiative to
develop
soft winter wheat varieties and spring
and winter barley varieties from the
northeastern u.s that have resistance if
usarium head blight
we collaborate with dr john lucianic
on a project
to
study the transcript transcriptomics and
metabolomics
and
to identify drivers of seed composition
and oat
pat hayes leads a project at oregon
state university
and we're involved in this project
titled multi-purpose organic naked
barley
elena vada manioc is in the crop science
department here at cornell and we work
with her on transcriptional regulation
of copper homeostasis in cereals and its
relationship to
fertility and grain yield
and then finally
we lead a usda organic research and
extension initiative project
titled value-added grains for local and
regional food systems
this project is focused on testing and
developing high-value food grains for
varieties in the northeast and midwest
growing regions
and it involves a collaboration with the
university of vermont
maine wisconsin illinois and south
dakota state university
so that gives you a little bit of an
overview about the small grains breeding
project at cornell university i hope to
see you around at the meetings and feel
free to contact me at any time with
questions or if you just want to chat
about small grains thank you very much
for listening today
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu